foreign
Calvin joins us Calvin how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking the call you
bet what's going on Calvin
so about two years ago I actually gave
my brother and his girlfriend about a 25
000 loan to help them buy a house and
in the time since that he's actually
paid me back his half but she's only
paid me back like 2 000 of it oh and so
I'm kind of wondering how can I bring
this up without it being like a huge
family fight you cannot
I was gonna say What's it been like tell
John uh what's it been like so far
because if your brothers paid his share
but she hasn't there's got to be some
conversations what do we know tell us
what we don't know
so I've talked to him about it and
basically what he told me is he has the
money she's capable of paying it back
but she's just choosing not to and he
can't explain to me why and someone
excited yeah and it's his wife he
doesn't want to talk trash about your
sister
he knows I guess but but how yeah I
don't know how to bring it up
you you cannot bring it up without it
becoming a thing you gotta you gotta you
gotta put that aside
you can do one of two things
you can say
congratulations sister I just gave you
twelve thousand dollars to buy a house
and I'm moving on with my life and you
can internally know I'll never give you
money ever again for as till the end of
time
or you can sit down and say it's been
this long and
um I need to we need to we need to lay
out a payment plan and put it in writing
when I need this money back
and she can lose her mind and get mad
and all that and such it is those are
your two choices man
yeah the thing is he she has the money
it doesn't matter she's not paying you
you know why because she doesn't have to
yeah you just gotta make a decision am I
gonna do this one or am I gonna do this
one
but I wanna I wanna ask a question
Calvin John just laid out two really
awesome clear options and your response
was but she has the money what does that
have to do with what he said there's
something you're still tripping up on
what do you what do you mean by that why
is that your response to him
when I gave him the loan I didn't
realize I was giving half of it to her I
thought it was just a loan between me my
brother
and and I wouldn't personally have given
her the money but now that I then he
told me after that they're going to pay
it back half and half so I just feel
like I got a little bit duped the other
side of this is so I I misunderstood I
was thinking this was your sister and
your brother-in-law paid this is your
brother and his wife
yeah his girlfriend his girlfriend his
girlfriend which makes it even weirder
um let's let me tell you this if some
weird twist of fate I had borrowed money
from my brother
um with my girlfriend to buy a house
I would feel some sort of obligation for
the other half especially if I'm still
living in this house
I think he does and he's brought up that
he wants to pay back but she won't let
him because she doesn't want to owe him
rather than me but now it's just coming
this twisted like I do think your
brother's playing you that's what you
feel and I'm starting to lean that way
John am I wrong I would get so far away
from them dude
your brother's not treating you with
Integrity their relationship is weird I
don't want to owe the guy that I'm
creating a life with and sharing a house
then then they've got deeper issues than
than this dude thanksgiving's not worth
this how close are you two
we we're extremely close like he's like
my best friend does that change it John
he's your best friend except that he
doesn't tell you the truth and he uh
isn't like a person of character when it
comes to borrowing money
Calvin I'm asking John a question on
your behalf okay I do believe
that that in in Calvin's mind his
brother is his best friend I hear what
you're saying I don't think the
brother's acting like a true best friend
agreed however
I'm asking this from a completely like
just common sense if this were my
brother and I have a brother
um and we were close
it would be it would be on like Donkey
Kong like dude
you figured out with a girlfriend you
duped me you this you this you this this
ain't right I want to do this to your
girlfriend right I'll just call the
brother card I feel like this is a
man-to-man I didn't say ugly or or nasty
or physical but am I wrong this changes
the equation no I think you gotta call
the brother card out and go Brothers
don't do this to each other dude you
gotta solve this brother's got a hug man
yeah you owe me the money and you
figured out with girlfriend but him
choosing girlfriend over you I think's a
cop out and I'd call the brother card
that would be me and then do what John
said but at the end of the day you got
to choose am I am I just gonna wash my
hands of this stuff and move on with my
life or am I gonna am I gonna cause the
scene there is no there's no like right
or wrong answer there
but listen yeah keep
this sentence in your mind for the rest
of your life behavior is a language
and what your brother is telling you is
that he thinks he's above you
and he doesn't really care that you
bailed him and his girlfriend out to buy
a house
and your brother's girlfriend is telling
you I couldn't care the last second
about you so true I don't like you I
don't care about you I took your money
and hahaha
that's what their behavior is telling
you
and that and listen to me like carefully
that hurts man like beneath me and Ken
like beneath me joking and being that
hurts because brothers are not supposed
to treat each other that way people that
you loan money to to help out are
supposed to be people of integrity and
pay their money back
that just hurts
have you called him out at all I mean
real real have you ever talk to him
to him if we talk it just turns into oh
I don't know she just doesn't want to
yeah and I can't get any farther than
that that's why I'm getting the point do
I just call her and talk to her
absolutely yeah
yeah I think he's kicked a can to you
anyway and and well I actually love what
you just said that's actually phenomenal
is that yours or somebody else's case I
steal it I need to give credit what's
that behavior is a language yeah that's
just across the board yeah I like the
way you said it yeah my point is is that
I think his behavior
is telling his brother like the the
Calvin's brother is saying I'm kicking
the can to her absolutely I don't want
to deal with this confrontation but if
you do call her call her with some very
specific requests don't call her and be
like hey when are you uh
call her and say I need the
um full amount of this repaid by this
date or what
I'm going to call the small claims court
I'm going to fill in the blank
and are you ready to walk are you ready
to fight for this
no I don't really need the money it's
more just like the disrespect I guess of
her not caring about it
and him not carrying you keep letting
him off the hook man he's a part of this
I think he's the culture that's what I'm
thinking I might just forget about it
well I didn't say you had to do that I
was just curious where your spirit was
on this because John's giving you great
advice here you know walk away or give
it one last shot but you got to decide
it's got to be one of the other you need
closure yes
yeah they just they keep bringing up
like they're going to remodel their
house they're trying to buy a second
house and it's just getting to the point
where I'm like that's why I do more
about that stuff they're just spitting
on you man yeah I I gotta know why why
are you letting your brother off the
hook here
because I love the guy like I want him
to be happy you know I love my brother
with all my heart but there's also
accountability
yeah that's true
John I feel like he's gonna go from
loving to resenting here soon you are
about to yeah and uh this is from the
greatest of Pharrell
always
always choose guilt over resentment
every time
because what you don't want to do is
wake up in three years and hate your
brother
and if she turns into his wife and their
kid turns into your nephew you don't
want to hate them
and so choose guilt over resentment
every time
feel guilty about making the call and
being very direct and putting down some
things in writing
it's gonna feel weird it's going to feel
guilty because like you said I love him
I want him to be happy and have a good
life absolutely and
you want him to do what he said he was
going to do
I'm sorry man that's I I'm just my
heart's broken my heart's broken for you